[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight
over the weekend americans gathered
around the country
in churches and synagogues to pray for
the 11
innocent people who were murdered in
pittsburgh on saturday they bowed their
heads they asked god for healing
they thought hard about how to bring the
country together how to improve
themselves
how to be kinder to the people around
them that's the america that you grew up
in
a decent place full of decent people
trying to do the right thing
but there's another america too it's the
america of cable news and social media
of cnn and twitter
in that america political operatives
rushed to the scene of human tragedy
hoping to leverage it for political gain
they make snap judgments on the basis of
incomplete evidence
in order to implicate their political
opponents in crimes they did not commit
they use fear and rage to accomplish
what reasoned
argument could never accomplish they
commit moral blackmail
typically their aim is gun control a
crazy person committed an evil act
therefore you must be disarmed but this
time that's not their goal this time
their goal is more comprehensive than
that
they want to take charge of what you are
allowed to say
and think how are they trying to do that
by blaming you
and your opinions for the crime watch
this man was the flames of his hatred
were fanned by a president who kept
talking
about this caravan of refugees as if
they were terrorists or as if they were
coming to commit atrocious crimes in our
country which they're not
so did you catch the message there it
wasn't subtle
the murderer was angry about illegal
immigration
if you oppose illegal immigration you
are very much like the murderer
even if you've never killed anyone your
views have inspired
others to kill you are implicated in
this atrocity
you are a monster just like the lunatic
in pittsburgh
you must change your beliefs otherwise
you will be punished
this is how free speech dies and free
thought
along with it the range of acceptable
opinion
narrows until it mimics a cnn script
before long everyone is nodding piously
along in unison
there is no disagreement there is only
conformity
obedient serfs chirping the party line
that's the goal after a century of
defending free speech the left is now
its
enemy just last week the southern
poverty law center issued a list of
demands for tech
companies anyone who disagrees with the
splc they explained
must be prevented from operating a
website or raising money online or
organizing events
or publicly expressing their opinions
that's an order
says the splc what goes without saying
that the southern poverty law center has
no
moral standing to make any of those
demands none of the people making
demands do
and yet as always the least virtuous are
invariably the most
self-righteous watch former dnc chairman
howard dean explained that
american politics is no longer really
about politics which is to say about
competing ideas of what might work and
what doesn't work
instead politics is a spiritual battle
between light and dark
between god and satan himself watch
it's now become a struggle about good
versus evil and the president of the
united states
is evil evil
now that is not the language of american
civic life it never has been
that is the language of holy war evil
well evil people can't be reasoned with
they shouldn't be listened to
they must be crushed and destroyed
did howard dean really mean that well
we're going to assume for the sake of
this country
that he did not mean that and none of
the other people talking like howard
dean right now
mean it either we're hoping all of them
have lost their senses temporarily
and at some point they're going to wake
up feeling chastened and ashamed
and ready to rejoin the adult
conversation in progress
that's our hope either way we do not
plan to stop talking no matter what they
say no matter what they demand
every american has an absolute right to
express his views regardless of what
twitter thinks
it's our birthright it's the most
important freedom we have
we're not giving it up on this show on
our set you are always free to say what
you believe
even if we disagree with you free
expression does not cause extremism
it solves extremism victor davis hanson
is a senior fellow at the hoover
institution and he joins us tonight
professor hanson i wanted to talk to you
first tonight because i think you have
perspective that
is lacking in this conversation are we
overstating it do you think
that speech is at stake in our current
debate
no i i i think it is in a way i i think
all of us though want a safe space if i
could use that left-wing term where we
we don't want to turn the television for
nba nfl or
grammys or tony's or white house course
and be lectured at
and we don't we don't want to spend
thanksgiving as if it's 1861.
so we want we want it to tone down but
we don't know what the rules are tucker
because
we sort of established that james
hodgkinson to take one
example did not shoot steve scalise
because of what biden
and maxine waters or madonna said on
inauguration day he was just nuts and
that might have
he had other you know criteria but it
wasn't just what
the opponents of donald trump or the
conservatives said okay we accept that
and then all of a sudden with these
latest two incidents with the pipe
bomber mr sayak
and with the synagogue shootings we're
told that it's somehow donald trump but
it's not
we don't know anything about the cause
and effect we don't know whether he was
too pro-israel and therefore he brought
people out of the woodwork they're angry
with him
or that he was too anti-israel and he
empowered the alt-right
they can't even get it straight so we
don't get the american people think well
wait a minute
i don't like hate speech or tough speech
but i don't know what the rules are
they're not it's not symmetrical it
looks like it's a left-wing
electronic you know reign of terror
these these self-appointed facebook
robespierre
in a nanosecond can guillotine you and
they don't people don't like that so
we're saying what are the rules
of speech and from what you and i and
others have seen of facebook and twitter
and youtube
the masters of the universe and silicon
lack either the intellect or the
morality
to tell us what is permissible speech so
we don't we don't know what
who to turn to this confusion so maybe
we just
go back to the sermon on the mount and
say to ourselves let's treat people the
way
we would like to treat and i would tell
that to to hillary clinton maybe when
when mitt romney lost in 2012 he didn't
say
i'm not going to be civil until the next
election or
when george bush quite graciously
accepted
that you know that he was out of office
in 2009 he didn't go around the country
as obama is now
calling the president united states an
inveterate liar
so i think it's asymmetrical and people
understand that until the adjudicators
know
they can't adjudicate us because they
don't have the
the moral high ground well they
definitely don't have the moral
authority to decide who speaks
but i wonder if their assumption is
right so what they're saying is that
certain ideas
are so bad that they cause violence
yeah and i wonder if it's even possible
for any society to ever
squelch ideas doesn't that
cause and i'm not just saying this is a
left-right phenomenon to human
phenomenon when you try and prevent
people from having
unapproved thoughts don't you create
extremism
yeah i think that's an age-old dilemma
it goes back to the greeks and we in the
west have decided
that we don't want the medicine to be
worse than the disease
of censorship and setting up a sensor
board
that tells us who can say what so we we
err on the side of free speech and it's
especially
uh pertinent when the people who are
wanting
to censor free speech right now don't
want to do it symmetrically
they feel that because they're more
noble or that donald trump is some type
of ogre that they have deserved
because of their noble ends any means
necessary to further their
moral project and i think that's got
people very very angry and
and sort of alienated well i mean
anytime
you have what is in effect a religious
conversation a theological conversation
that begins with i'm a good person and
you're not
how can you hope to make progress how
can you solve anything
if one side believes itself to be saved
in the other damned
yeah you can't and you have to be
empirical so you have to say this
particular act
in this particular person's mind
occurred because he heard this
particular person say something
or a climate nobody's been able to make
that cause and effect and in absence of
that
as i said in a nanosecond all these half
educated people get on at some of the
clips you pay
and then they say i accuse you of all
this and nobody everybody's afraid i
mean
one you are you and i are one and you
especially are one nanosecond away
one slipped word from being your head
electronically chopped off
yep and that's that's what we don't want
every day i think that but i think it's
important more important than it's ever
been to tell the truth
and be honest uh thank you professor
it's great well you have to speak up
against it
yeah i think it's thank you